STUDENT: So I believe
this is kind of working.
And this looks cool.
STUDENT: Can you do [INAUDIBLE]?
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: OK.
[INAUDIBLE] how quiet it is.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
Dance off.
STUDENT: But yeah.
It's really cool.
So we actually finally
got the Run Model online.
And what it is, if you
look at the [INAUDIBLE],,
it's actually split into
a lot of different things,
like the pelvis.
And then it goes into
legs and then knees.
So basically what we did
is we moved it like this.
For the wifi, we matched the
left hip and then knee to knee,
and so.
We just went through each
of the different parts.
And also one thing
to keep note of--
STUDENT: Cool.
STUDENT: For easy access for
the arms and legs because
with Connect, it
would go weirdly.
Like your arms would
be going backwards.
ABHINAV GANDHI: At
first it was almost as
if my body was backwards.
Like I was in Godzilla
suit in backwards.
So I looked really,
really weird.
Very scary.
The idea was supposed
to be Kinect.
But we seem to be experiencing
some issues with the Kinect.
But the initial
game with Kinect was
that, you would have to
move your body in order
to avoid the obstacles.
KYLE KEANE: Giant Spiderman?
STUDENT: Including
the Spiderman.
He tries to tell people
he can't do anything.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENTS: No.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
Make sure to walk on them.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[STUDENTS GASPING]
MARK VRABLIC: So
used this as a--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: So if you kill too
many people, then you lose.